[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
thursday august 25th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
in beijing's regulatory crackdown on
tech one of the hardest hit sectors has
been video games
what's more china's economy has been
weakening under kovitt 19 restrictions
meaning fewer people are spending money
on games and in-game purchases
so how are chinese video game makers
adapting
joining us to talk about it is our china
tech reporter shenlu
hey shenlu thanks for joining me hi zoe
thanks for having me
let's start with the situation in china
now what are video game makers facing
the video game developers large and
small have burned the brand of
regulatory crackdown for the past
year
since last year our authorities in china
have approved significantly fewer games
than before and tightened censorship of
video games and restricted play time
significantly for
young gamers and for some eight months
china's regulators didn't grant any
licenses to new games and that freeze
was lifted in april but game makers are
getting far fewer titles approved this
year
china has had some pretty tough
censorship rules for a while how is this
situation different in terms of getting
games approved so you're right china has
been curbing the video game sector since
2018
in 2018 authorities froze title approval
for some nine months
and then they froze the title approvals
again in 2021 the restrictions were
lifted
in april but video game makers we talked
to for the story told us that now the
timeline for getting title approval is
much longer
which means after investing a lot of
money in making video games and
operating them and buying server storage
they can't charge users until they get
their title approval so when the
application is stuck in the queue they
can't make money off of their games
what are authorities looking for are
there specific things that the the
sensors are objecting to
that's a billion dollar question
everybody wants to know the video game
developers certainly want to know why
the authorities are delaying approving
and what they are actually looking for
in the video game content people we've
talked to told us that the process has
largely been non-transparent
but late last year executives at video
game developers participated in a
workshop where authorities told them
certain contents were not allowed in
video game content and those include
same-sex relationships transgender
identities or
what authorities deemed fabricated
historical events
i know another challenge that they're
facing that we've talked about on this
show before is the limit of play time
that china has placed on young gamers
those under 18. you know so given all of
these challenges chinese video game
makers are starting to look overseas how
were they doing that
so so far video game developers big and
small are looking for opportunities
overseas for example tencent the world's
largest video game maker
has doubled down on buying and joining
with foreign studios this year not ease
china's second largest video game
developer has opened two new studios
abroad at least this year and less known
chinese video game publishers like
mihoyo and litusgames have also
established their global publishing
labels to cater to an international
audience overseas so it's a mix of
acquiring studios and partnering with
studios or buying ips and establishing
their own global headquarters and
publishing labels
how big of a shift is this i mean is
this chinese video game company saying
you know we're just too big for our
current market or is this a full
recalibration of their current business
structure and their business strategy
large companies are more concerned about
future growth opportunities so they're
actively exploring new growth
opportunities overseas as we see
the number of game players and the
revenue from the chinese games market
both
declined in the first half of 2022 but
the revenue from overseas has grown so
this is one of the main reasons why
chinese companies are actively
accelerating their
expansion overseas but for smaller
companies the tighter regulation which
means chinese regulators are approving
fewer
new titles each year now is detrimental
to the smaller companies businesses
because they are waiting for the
approval of new games to be able to
monetize the games so for a lot of video
game developers there's a new urgency
around expanding their businesses
overseas because many think that they if
they don't expand to overseas markets
they're gonna die in the domestic market
how are chinese regulators reacting to
this shift overseas are they concerned
at all about chinese game makers uh
starting to sell more overseas
so far we haven't seen any sign of
chinese regulators being concerned about
video game developers expanding overseas
in fact
they are encouraging video game
developers and other content makers to
sort of export their content and the
chinese culture overseas because that's
um because china also wants to exert its
soft power overseas and video game is a
great venue for that
so i wonder what this means then for
video game players and and for the
company's kind of long-term outlooks is
this going to change kind of how they
see themselves going forward
yeah so several large video game makers
have said they're going to focus on
global players instead of focusing on
just one geographic region
and that is particularly its ceo has
said that they want their
international game revenue to account
for about half of its total game revenue
which is a significant jump from the
current 10 percent so that tells us
about how overseas market is important
for
chinese video game makers now
all right that's our china tech reporter
shen liu chan lu thanks so much for
joining us thank you so much for having
me zoe
and that's today's tech news briefing if
you're looking for more tech stories
head over to wsj.com and if you enjoy
this show how about leaving us a
five-star rating and a review wherever
you get your podcasts i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you